I'm profoundly saddened by the passing
of Nelson Mandela Nelson Mandela was a
giant for justice and the down toward
the human inspiration many around the
world were greatly influenced by his a
selfless struggle for human dignity
equality and freedom he touched our
lives in deeply personal ways at the
same time no one did more in our time to
advance the values and aspirations of
the United Nations Nelson Mandela showed
what is possible for our world and
within each one of us if we believe a
dream and work together for justice and
humanity his moral force was a decisive
in dismantling the system of appetite
remarkably he merged from 27 of
detention without rancor determined to
build a new South Africa based on
dialogue and reconciliation I was
privileged to meet Nelson Mandela in
February 2009 when I thanked him for his
life's work he insisted the credit
belongs to others I will never forget
his selflessness and deep sense of
shared purpose on behalf of the United
Nations I extend my deepest condolences
to Nelson Mandela's family the people of
South Africa and indeed our global
family let us continue each day to be
inspired by Nelson Mandela's lifelong
example to keep walking for a better and
more just world thank you